الشمس والقمر
بحسبان
والنجم والشجر يسجدان
[موسيقى]
عندما حفيظ القران
ذهبنا الى جنوب افريقيا
بدرلوم
زكريا هناك بجنوب افريقيا هناك ايضا راجعت
القران الكامل مع الشيخ عبد الرشيد توبيا
[موسيقى]
حينما يعني اعيش مع اصحاب العرب مثلا اهل
لبنان واهل سوريا دائما انا اتعلم مع
الشيوخ كمان ولكن بدات التعليم اللغه
العربيه بجنوب افريقيا حينما دخلتم في
الجامعه دار العلوم زكريا هناك كانوا
اساتذتنا من بنغلا من باكستان والهندي هم
يتكلمون اللغه الارديه
وبالنسبه يعني لغتهم نحن ايضا تعلمنا لغه
لغه الارديه
[موسيقى]
اول ما جيت هنا في البرازيل الحمد لله
يعني
ذهبت الى هذا المكان لندرينا وقرانا
القران هناك في شهر رمضان يعني لم تكن
يعني قراءه مثلا القراء لا ولكن مرتل
ترتيل
يعني للصلوات التراويح وبعدما
انتهينا شهر رمضان
قالوا ان فيه مسجد هناك ايضا في نفس يعني
في نفس الولايه في مسجد كانت تقريبا
مسكر يعني مغلق مغلق ليش لان لم يكن فيها
عالم لم يكن في شيخ اذا طلبوا من لكي اشوف
هذا الجامعه هل يمكن لي ان اكون هناك حتى
يعني
يعني نحافظ المسجد ونذر الناس لكي نبدا
يعني بالتجديد هذا المسجد والحمد لله
حينما زرت هذا الجاميه الى الان الجامعه
يسمى جامعه
[موسيقى]
مسجد السلام ذهبنا الى هناك وكنت الحمد
لله امام هناك تقريبا بسته سنوات
[موسيقى]